.
Sairah kam in Indien zur Welt
und wurde adoptiert.
Fast 40 Jahre später reist sie zurück
und sucht ihre Familie.
Es ist irgendwie ein schönes Gefühl.
Eine Reise in meine Vergangenheit.
Ich bin jetzt irgendwie
näher an meinen Wurzeln.
Barbara Crole flüchtete im
Zweiten Weltkrieg aus Deutschland -
heutiges Polen. Nach 75 Jahren wagt
sie eine Reise in die Vergangenheit.
Wir waren nur unglücklich
und hatten Hunger. Immer.
Ach, du Arme.
* Schluchzen *
Das ist eine Reise
zurück zu den Wurzeln.
Eine Reise in "Meine fremde Heimat".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Eine Gemeinde im Kanton Zürich.
Hier wohnt Sairah Benz.
Mit drei Jahren wurde sie in Indien
von Schweizern adoptiert.
Heute hat sie keinen Kontakt mehr
zu ihren Adoptiveltern.
Vor einer Weile hat sich Sairah
auch noch von ihrem Mann getrennt.
Mit ihm hat sie
eine fünfjährige Tochter.
Nun will sie endlich
ihre Ursprungsfamilie kennenlernen.
Für mich fühlt es sich nun gut an,
v.a. mit dem Ziel,
nach Indien zu reisen.
Ich habe mich mein Leben lang
etwas allein gefühlt.
Und ...
Durch die Reise, also den Schritt,
den ich bald mache,
nach Indien zu gehen ...
Vielleicht finde ich da jemanden,
damit ich nicht mehr allein bin.
Ich habe diesen Schritt gewagt, weil
ich mich selbst nicht mehr spürte.
* Indische Klänge *
Sairah ist schon lange
auf der Suche nach Antworten
auf Fragen zu ihrem Leben.
Sie spürt Dinge,
die sie sich nicht erklären kann.
Manchmal sieht sie einen Schatten,
der sie begleitet.
Darum geht sie zu einer Botschafterin
der geistigen Welt.
Irgendetwas ruft mich.
Täglich ist jemand bei mir,
der mich begleitet.
Nicht nur am Abend, sondern
auch während des ganzen Tags.
Ich möchte gerne herausfinden,
wer das ist.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es hat
sehr viel mit meiner Familie zu tun.
Heute geht sie zu ihrem Medium.
Sie möchte wissen,
was sie in Indien erwartet
und ob sie endlich mehr
über ihre Familie herausfindet.
Hallo. Hoi.
Schön, dich wieder mal zu sehen.
Hallo, hoi, Sairah. Hoi, hoi, hoi.
Hey. Schön, bist du hier.
Danke.
- Kommt rein!
Wir gehen gleich ins Wohnzimmer.
So, Sairah.
Ich denke,
du mischst mir zuerst die Karten.
Wir haben von dir
ja keine Geburtszeiten,
nicht mal das genaue Geburtsdatum.
Einfach, damit ich reinkomme.
Welche Karten möchtest du gern?
Die kleineren oder die grösseren,
die festlicheren?
Ich will die festlicheren. Gold.
Gut. Das passt.
Du trägst ja auch Gold.
Ja.
Also, misch sie einfach mal
und denk an deinen Wunsch.
"Ich möchte gern wissen,
wo meine Verwandten sind."
"Habe ich eine Chance?"
Konzentrier dich wirklich darauf.
Gut.
- Super, danke.
So haben wir eine Landkarte
von deiner Geschichte.
Was mir schon mal auffällt,
auch wenn ich die Karten
nicht einzeln erkläre:
Sairah ist die Karte Nummer 29,
und sie ist auf Platz 2.
Das ist das Kleeblatt,
d.h., wir haben Glück.
Wir haben Glück mit diesem Projekt.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
Ich verbinde mich nun einfach,
erkläre nicht alles einzeln,
aber schaue mir das mal an.
Ich sehe, dass du auf einem Platz
bist, wo ein grosser Fluss ist.
Der Fluss
macht eine ziemliche Kurve.
Und ich sehe Wasserflaschen.
Es muss dort ... Ich bekomme
Gänsehaut, das ist ein Zeichen.
Es muss da eine Fabrik
oder so haben,
wo Trinkwasser hergestellt wird.
Oder irgend so etwas.
Da muss jemand arbeiten.
Ich glaube, dass ihr weiterkommt,
wenn ihr zu diesem Platz geht.
Ich spüre,
dass es dort Verwandte gibt.
Ich glaube ...
Was ich auch bekomme, ist, dass
man sie nicht gern abgegeben hat.
Es hat wehgetan, sie abzugeben.
- Das habe ich auch.
Was ich herausspüre, ist,
dass ich als Kleinkind,
die ersten zweieinhalb Jahre,
in denen ich dort war,
sehr viel Liebe bekommen habe.
- Okay.
Danach bin ich nun auf der Suche.
- Ganz genau.
Auch sie ... auch dich.
Ich spüre
auch noch eine Grossmutter.
Da muss
ein ziemlicher Familienbund sein.
Es ist eine grosse Familie. Ja.
Ja. Und das tut einfach sehr weh.
Warst du mal in Indien?
- Nein.
Gar nie. Okay.
Also ...
Ich spüre es auf jeden Fall.
Meine Frage ist nun einfach, ob die
Adoptionspapiere auffindbar sind.
Das könnte schwierig werden.
Ja, das könnte schwierig werden.
Barbara Crole und ihr Mann Markus
sind unterwegs nach Lütjenburg
im Norden Deutschlands.
Siehst du, du kannst nicht sagen,
es sei ganz flach. Die leichte ...
Mit dem Rad würde man es
noch mehr spüren. - Ja, ja.
Am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
flüchtete Barbara mit ihrer Familie
aus ihrem Heimatort Kolberg
über die Ostsee.
In Lütjenburg
verbrachte sie eine schlimme Zeit.
An Lütjenburg habe ich
sehr gemischte Erinnerungen.
Ich ging eigentlich da weg, sobald
ich konnte. Mit 19, nach dem Abitur.
Mir blieben natürlich die
schrecklichen Jahre nach dem Krieg
mehr in Erinnerung,
wo die Leute nicht freundlich waren.
Die Leute
waren ja völlig überfordert.
Es gab nichts zu essen,
es gab ... nichts.
Das waren keine Unmenschen. Sie
sahen, dass die Flüchtlinge litten.
Aber das letzte Stück Brot teilen,
das war dann eben doch nicht drin.
Barbara Crole und Markus Wieser
wohnen in Lausanne.
Er kommt aus dem Appenzellerland,
sie kam als junge Frau wegen
ihrer Ausbildung in die Schweiz.
Das stelle ich da hin.
Die zwei haben sich
bei der Arbeit kennengelernt
und sind über 40 Jahre verheiratet.
Für beide ist es die zweite Ehe.
Seit wir pensioniert sind,
sind wir ein Team.
Vorher fuhr Markus
jeden Tag nach Bern.
Und ich hatte ja ein Beratungsbüro
und habe hier gearbeitet.
Das kommt da rein.
Ich war viel unterwegs, nicht wahr?
Aber mein Büro war hier.
Hast du noch einen Löffel?
- Ja.
Das war schon eine Umgewöhnung
nach der Pensionierung,
als wir plötzlich den ganzen Tag
zusammen waren, nicht, Markus?
Oh ja.
* Klingel *
Muss ich noch ...
Bonjour!
Salut, Markus!
Ca va? Wie geht's?
- Herzlich willkommen.
Danke. Ich mache nicht zu,
da Nina auch noch kommt.
Salut.
Heute kommen Anna und Nina,
Barbaras Töchter aus erster Ehe.
Oh, du hast schon bestellt.
* Klingel *
Ca va?
Schön, dass du hier bist.
Extra aus Genf gekommen.
Bist du im Auto gekommen
oder mit der Bahn?
Auto. Ist einfacher.
Nicht so gut, aber einfacher.
Bon appetit.
Die Reise in die fremde Heimat ist
seit Wochen ein Thema in der Familie.
Barbara war seit ihrer Flucht
nie mehr in Kolberg,
wo sie die ersten Jahre gelebt hat
und wo ihr Elternhaus steht.
Ich denke immer, was mir das wohl
ausmacht, wenn ich das Haus sehe.
Im März 1945 -
Barbara war damals sechs Jahre alt -
musste sie ihr Zuhause von einem
auf den nächsten Tag verlassen.
Sie flüchtete
mit ihren jüngeren Schwestern,
ihrer Mutter und Verwandten.
Kolberg gehörte damals
noch zu Deutschland.
Die Stadt
wurde nach dem Krieg polnisch.
"In diesen Tagen vor 50 Jahren
berannten sowjetische
und polnische Truppen
die pommersche Hafenstadt Kolberg."
"Sie war
mit Flüchtlingen überfüllt."
"Wenig mehr als 3'000 deutsche
Soldaten verteidigten die Stadt."
Das war die Stadt. Das ist
die letzte Erinnerung, die ich habe.
Die letzte Erinnerung ist das?
- Schrecklich.
Da ist schon alles zerbombt.
Ja. Es war schon zerbombt,
als wir weggingen.
Da war einfach nichts übrig.
Ist das das Jahr,
in dem du weggegangen bist?
Aber ...
Vas-y!
Omi hat mir gesagt, sie konnte
die Stiefel der Russen hören.
Ah! Ich darf gar nicht vorlesen.
Eines Tages haben wir beschlossen,
dass wir fliehen müssen.
Die Russen kamen immer näher.
Wir haben am Nachmittag
noch zusammen Kaffee getrunken,
mit Kuchen.
Dann gingen wir zusammen zum Hafen.
Da kam das Schiff,
mit dem wir hätten fliehen sollen.
Dann haben wir gesehen, wie
ein Schiff auf der Mine explodierte.
Alle waren tot.
Mein Vater - nein, mein Grossvater
kannte den Hafenmeister.
Da konnten wir übernachten.
Dann kamen wir aufs Schiff,
wo kaum mehr Platz war.
Wir waren also auf Deck,
es war saukalt draussen.
Uns allen wurde schlecht.
Eine Milchkanne wurde immer im Kreis
herumgereicht, zum reinkotzen.
Die wohlhabende Familie
musste alles zurücklassen.
Es ging nur noch ums Überleben.
Was sie am Ende dieser Flucht
übers Meer erwartet, wusste niemand.
Barbara und ihre Familie
reisten schliesslich
über zwei Jahre durch Deutschland -
von einem Ort zum nächsten.
Dann landeten sie
im kleinen Dorf Lütjenburg.
Da hatten die Leute
noch nie andere Leute gesehen,
und plötzlich
verzehnfachte sich die Bevölkerung.
Ich glaube, das hat uns am meisten
traumatisiert: Niemand wollte uns.
Und dann, nach diesem Haus ... So
lebten wir vier Kinder, zwei Eltern
und die Grossmutter in einem Zimmer,
mit der Toilette auf dem Hof.
Und nichts zu essen.
Ich ging immer betteln.
Da kannte ich nichts.
Ich klopfte und fragte:
Haben sie nicht was zu essen?
Es ist schrecklich, das zu hören.
In dieser Ausführlichkeit habe ich
es überhaupt noch nie gehört,
obwohl wir
schon viele Jahre zusammen sind.
Traumatisierte Leute. Oui, oui.
Aber ich weiss noch.
Irgendwann, ich weiss nicht wann,
habe ich gemerkt,
dass unser Kühlschrank
immer voll war.
* Barbara lacht. *
Aber ... bon. Ich war nie
an anderen Kühlschränken,
wenn ich das so sagen darf.
D.h., ich habe erst später gemerkt,
dass er bei uns immer voll war
und bei anderen vielleicht mal
drei Kartoffeln oder so drin waren.
Es war ganz anders.
Das sind solche Sachen.
Die Angst vor Hunger ist geblieben.
Und du hattest lange
ein Stück Brot in deiner Tasche.
Ja, ich hatte immer
ein Stück Brot dabei.
Immer, immer.
Ja, ja. Oh, Gott.
Der Hunger und die schlimme Flucht
hat Barbara hinter sich gelassen.
Aber die Erlebnisse
haben ihr Leben geprägt.
Jetzt, 75 Jahre später,
ist sie bereit, ihre alte Heimat
in Polen und in Deutschland
nochmals zu besuchen.
Ich will einfach gar nichts erwarten
und gar nichts erhoffen.
Ich will es einfach noch mal sehen.
Dann kann ich sterben.
Ich übertreibe jetzt.
Nicht gleich, nicht morgen.
Aber das ist so ein Abschluss
am Ende des Lebens, nicht?
Ähm ...
Ich muss mich dem noch mal stellen.
Der Vater deines Bruders.
- Ja, genau.
In ein paar Tagen
fliegt Sairah nach Indien,
ins Land, in dem sie zur Welt kam.
Begleitet wird sie
von einer guten Freundin, Natalia.
Die beiden haben sich bei der Arbeit
im Pflegeheim kennengelernt.
Hallo.
- Hoi, hoi.
Oh, willkommen. Schön.
Schön, dich zu sehen. Geht's gut?
Ja, sehr gut.
- Super. Komm herein.
Ja, danke.
Ich bin gespannt,
was du bei mir riechst.
Ja.
Du hast mir ja erzählt, es gebe Ge-
rüche, die dich an Indien erinnern.
Hm.
Darum habe ich
etwas Indisches gemacht.
Für mich ist das etwas ganz Neues.
Ich habe noch nie richtig
mit indischen Gewürzen gekocht.
Bei diesen wäre ich froh, wenn
du sie ... - Gut. Zupfen oder ...
Einfach gern fein schneiden.
Das dauert jetzt 25 Min.
Ich freue mich sehr, Sairah.
Ich mich auch. Ich mich auch.
Obwohl du schon
ziemlich durchbeissen musstest.
Alles?
- Ja, ja. Ist okay. Alles gut, ja.
Ja, ich habe
eine intensive Zeit hinter mir.
Eine intensive.
- Eine sehr intensive.
Aber mir geht's gut.
Ja.
Sairah hat Mühe damit,
dass sie fast nichts über
ihre leibliche Familie herausfindet.
Natalia hat sie bei dieser Suche
immer unterstützt.
Darum ist für Sairah klar,
dass sie zusammen nach Indien reisen.
Sie interessiert sich für mich,
und sie hört mir auch zu.
Ich spüre wirklich eine tiefe
Verbindung, die mir sehr gut tut.
Danke.
- Ja.
Sairah sucht schon seit einer Weile
ihre Adoptionsunterlagen.
Da könnte etwas
über ihre leibliche Familie stehen.
Ganz am Anfang,
als es mich interessierte,
fragte ich bei Terres des Hommes an,
ob sie evtl. noch Unterlagen haben.
Ich fuhr nach Lausanne und fragte.
Aber es sind leider
nicht mehr viele Papiere vorhanden.
Aber war etwas da, oder gar nichts?
Doch, etwas war da.
Was ich eben ...
* Sie räuspert sich. *
... von der Terre des Hommes
mitbekommen habe, ist dieses Foto.
Ja.
Ja, du, Sairah.
Das Schönste wäre natürlich,
wenn sie Geschwister, Verwandte
oder sogar ihre Mutter
finden könnte.
Wenn es dann aber nicht so ist,
denke ich, dass sicher trotzdem
einige Wurzeln ihrer Vergangenheit
erfühl- oder erkennbar werden.
Das hilft auch schon.
Meine Motivation,
nach Indien zu gehen, ist wirklich,
mein innerer Frieden
und meine Mutter zu finden.
Und meine Wurzeln zu entdecken.
Da, wo ich herkomme.
Diese Sehnsucht
habe ich jetzt ganz stark.
Ja.
Der Flug nach Kalkutta
dauert gut 12 Std.
Sairah war vor 20 Jahren
schon mal in Indien,
aber Natalia
ist noch nie so weit gereist.
Kalkutta
ist die drittgrösste Stadt Indiens.
Offiziell
leben hier 15 Mio. Menschen.
Inoffiziell spricht man von 30 Mio.
Hier beginnt Sairahs Suche.
In den wenigen Unterlagen, die sie
hat, steht Kalkutta als Geburtsort.
Es ist über 30 °C heiss,
und die Luft extrem feucht.
Sogar die Hunde liegen flach.
* Tragende Musik *
* Langgezogenes Hupen *
Es ist einfach lustig
mit diesem Hupen, nicht?
Trotz der langen Reise
bleiben die beiden nur kurz im Hotel.
Sie möchten Sairahs fremde Heimat
möglichst authentisch entdecken
und schmeissen sich
ins indische Alltagsleben.
Das sieht wie zerhackte Mandeln aus.
Zwiebeln, Kartoffeln, Gewürze.
Schau, eine Ratte!
Wo?
- Dort!
Kalkutta gehört
zu den ärmsten Städten der Welt.
Viele Bewohner müssen betteln,
um zu überleben.
Sorry. Sorry, we have to go.
- Don't say sorry. I'm very poor.
So. Gehen wir weiter.
* Hupen *
Natalia, komm. Wir müssen hier weg.
- Genau.
Weisst du, ich glaube,
jetzt müssen wir weg.
Du siehst nur das,
was du jetzt gesehen hast.
Ich sehe
auch ganz offensichtliche Armut.
Ja.
- Und sie sehen uns nur als Reiche.
Diese Frauen: Wenn ich sie anschaue,
habe ich Mitgefühl mit ihnen.
* Hupen *
Achtung!
Achtung! Jetzt sind wir
ein Verkehrshindernis.
* Hupen *
* Melancholische Streichklänge *
Ich bin froh,
dass ich nicht hier lebe.
dass ich in der Schweiz wohne.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass ich schon auch Mühe habe,
zu sehen,
wie diese Menschen hier leben.
Wenn ich die Menschen
hier auf dem Markt sehe.
Das ist das Städtchen Lütjenburg
in Norddeutschland.
Hier fing für Barbara
und ihre Familie
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
ein neues Leben an -
zusammen mit ein paar Tausend
anderen Flüchtlingen.
So. Willkommen in Lütjenburg -
was "kleine Stadt" heisst.
Lütt heisst klein.
Ich brauche mein Jackett nicht,
oder?
Die einzige Sehenswürdigkeit
ist das Haus da.
Dann haben wir's eigentlich gesehen.
Barbara war ewig nicht hier.
Sie erinnert sich ungern
an die Zeit in Lütjenburg.
Als Flüchtling
fühlte sie sich nicht willkommen.
Ihre Familie war arm,
und es gab nie genug zu essen.
Es scheint,
als würde der Hunger von damals
Barbara auch heute noch antreiben.
Hallo. Haben Sie grobe Mettwurst?
Grobe Mettwurst? In welche Richtung?
Was zum Streichen oder ...
Nee. Zum Schneiden. Ja, ja. Können
Sie mir ein Stück abschneiden?
Ein Stück?
- Ja, so ...
Ich halt mal ran,
und Sie sagen, ob das okay ist.
Länger.
- Mehr?
Oder ich nehme alles mit.
- Wie Sie möchten.
Aber können Sie es mir
einschweissen? - Natürlich.
So. Ausserdem noch ein Wunsch?
Willst du noch was, Markus?
Ach, Markus hat schon wieder
'ne Dame entdeckt. Uuh!
Darf das auch eingeschweisst werden?
- Sehr gerne, ja. * Sie lacht. *
Mensch, das reicht für zwei Wochen!
Ja, es ist auch die Hälfte.
* Beide lachen. *
Ich muss auch den Kindern was geben.
- Ja, klar.
Ich nehme das eine
und du das andere. - So ist es.
* Heitere Musik *
Der Ort ist Barbara
immer noch vertraut.
Aber in der Einkaufsstrasse
ist nichts mehr so wie damals.
Was ist das für ein Laden?
Das war nichts mit der Buchhandlung.
* Er lacht. *
Was machen die? Kannst du erk...
Du erkennst es auch nicht.
"Heilige Sau".
Das ist ein Kunstgeschäft.
- Ja, Kunstgewerbe.
Ja, ja. Und ein Bioladen.
* Prustendes Lachen *
Ja, also ...
Auch in Norddeutschland
ist man jetzt modern.
Mit Bio.
- Ja.
Früher war alles einfach bio, nicht?
Okay, gut.
Wollen wir da durchgehen
und dann links?
Das Bundesland Schleswig-Holstein
hat nach dem Krieg
so viele Flüchtlingen aufgenommen
wie kaum ein anderes.
Barbara sucht das Haus,
das sie mit ihrer Familie
und anderen Flüchtlingen bewohnt hat.
Sollen wir klingeln und fragen,
ob wir rein dürfen? - Klar.
Ja, ja.
Das war das Haus.
- Das links?
Das hier.
- Ja.
Und ...
In diesem Haus wohnten 28 Leute.
Und ... äh ...
Bevor wir kamen,
wohnte eine alte Dame da drin.
Diese Häuser gab es noch nicht.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
wie man da jetzt reinkommt.
Guten Tag. Entschuldigen Sie bitte.
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Ich bin Barbara Crole,
geborene Schulz.
Wir haben nach dem Krieg in diesem
Haus gewohnt - bei Minna Peters.
Ja.
Oben wohnte Minna Peters, nicht?
Sie hatte vorher das ganze Haus.
Dann musste die Arme
in der Dachkammer hausen.
Die Flüchtlinge
haben sich überall breitgemacht.
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen.
- Da war sie gar nicht happy.
* Barbara lacht. *
Und ... äh ...
Aber sie hat das hier erlebt.
- Sie hat es erlebt.
Siehst du?
Da waren die Toiletten drin.
Da war keine Toilette im Haus.
Die letzten beiden Türen
waren die Toiletten.
Ja.
Die erste Tür war der Hühnerstall.
Und dann die Waschküche.
Ja, ja. Genau.
Da war noch ein Waschkessel ...
Da war ein richtiger Kessel.
Der wurde kürzlich entfernt.
Dürfen wir mal zur Toilette da?
Um ihm das zu zeigen?
Machen Sie nur.
- Gut, danke.
Das ist jetzt ...
Eben. Das waren die Toiletten.
Da musste man
bei Nacht und Nebel über den Hof.
Da ...
Jetzt ist zu.
Äh ...
Das waren früher Plumpsklos.
Das nannte man so.
Das wurde
zweimal im Jahr ausgeleert.
Es stank bestialisch im Sommer.
Und im Winter war es gefroren.
Hier habe ich sehr gelitten.
Meine Schwestern sind gestorben.
Wir waren nur unglücklich.
Und wir hatten Hunger. Immer.
Aber da es uns allen so ging ...
Ich war kein Einzelschicksal.
Es ging Millionen so.
Wir haben das einfach hingenommen.
Wie können Leute das aushalten?
Aber Leute halten alles aus.
Man arrangiert sich im Unglück.
Und wenn es so viele gibt,
die unglücklich sind,
dann ist das auch eine Gemeinschaft.
* Schwermütige Musik *
Zurück in Indien.
Am zweiten Tag wollen
Sairah und Natalia in Kalkutta
Sairahs leibliche Familie finden.
Sie wissen, dass sie mit drei
in ein Kinderheim kam.
Es ist aber nicht klar,
ob ihre leiblichen Eltern
sie dort abgegeben haben oder ob sie
als Strassenkind gefunden wurde.
Es ist ein Bedürfnis von dir,
diesen Ort zu finden, nicht wahr?
Du möchtest nochmals dort stehen,
wo dieses Kinderheim war.
Ich werde ein wenig nervös.
Es berührt dich, nicht?
* Hupen *
Jetzt bist du irgendwie nahe dran,
nicht?
Sairah weiss, dass das Kinderheim
irgendwo in dieser Gegend war.
Hello.
Two teas, please.
Mmh. Da ist viel Zucker drin.
Weil sie kein Hindi spricht,
hat sich Sairah
mit einer Übersetzerin verabredet,
die sie heute unterstützt.
Hallo, Dorotea. Natalia.
Willkommen in Kalkutta.
Du suchst ja deine Mutter.
Wie kann ich dir weiterhelfen?
Ich suche meine Mutter, ja.
Und ich suche auch das Kinderheim,
in dem ich damals war.
Hast du Unterlagen dazu?
- Ja, habe ich.
Gut.
Wir sind in der richtigen Strasse.
Und so weit ich weiss ist
die Nummer 4 das dritte Haus hier.
Lass uns da mal hingehen.
- Ja.
* Abwartende Musik *
Dort oben ist das weisse Gebäude,
das ich immer gesehen habe.
Das gegenüber?
- Ja.
Trimurti.
Daran erinnerst du dich?
Ja, das war es.
Was hast du jetzt gesagt?
- Woran erinnerst du dich genau?
Trimurti ist der Name, der auch
in meinem Pass steht. Die Adresse.
Und hier die unterste ...
Ja, genau das.
Warst du öfter auf dem Balkon?
- Ja.
Ich war öfter da.
Die Leute,
die Kinder adoptieren wollten,
hatten die Gelegenheit, zu uns
zu kommen und uns anzuschauen.
Damit das Heim
einen guten Eindruck machte,
mussten wir vor dem Essen immer
Bewegungs- und Turnübungen machen.
Und ... manchmal hatte ich
wirklich keinen Bock darauf,
den Hampelmann
vor den Gästen zu machen.
Da musste ich zur Strafe
auf den Balkon.
Ich war oft auf dem Balkon.
Ja.
- Lass uns mal reingehen.
Das Kinderheim gibt es nicht mehr.
In diesem Haus sind heute Wohnungen.
Namaste.
Namaste. - Namaste.
- Thank you very much.
Can I go through?
Wow.
Ich sass meist hier unten.
Mach doch mal. Setz dich!
Oder ich kniete hier.
Denkst du gerade daran?
- Ja, ich kniete hier.
Du holst es gerade zurück.
- Ich starrte das Gebäude da an.
Und ausgehalten.
- Und ausgehalten.
Es ist irgendwie ein schönes Gefühl.
Es ist eine Reise
in meine Vergangenheit.
Verarbeitung.
Meine Wurzeln. Ich bin
näher an meinen Wurzeln - jetzt.
* Melancholische Musik *
Das sind keine bitteren Wurzeln,
keine bitteren Gefühle.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Es tut mir gut.
Es gehört zu meinem Leben, Natalia.
Ich kann es nicht wegdenken.
Es war nichts Schlechtes.
Und es ist dir auch nicht
so schlecht ergangen. - Nein.
Überhaupt nicht.
Es ist ein grosser Teil
des Anfangs deines Lebens,
den du jetzt kennst,
den du einordnen kannst.
Ja.
Und das tut dir gut.
- Ja.
Ja.
So schön.
Good bye.
- Good bye. - And bless you.
Thank you. Namaskar.
* Melancholische Musik *
In Lütjenburg hat Barbara heute
einen schwierigen Besuch vor sich.
Wir müssen auf die andere Seite.
Hier ist denn auch gleich das Grab.
Hier sind ihre Eltern begraben, ihre
Grosseltern und ihre zwei Schwestern:
Christine und Ute.
* Sanfte, ergreifende Musik *
Du bist mir etwas zu schnell.
Barbara.
- Was? - Langsamer, bitte.
Da sind wir ja schon.
* Sanfte, ergreifende Musik *
Da ist die Christine.
Und Ute.
Da sind meine Grosseltern.
Ich hätte eigentlich
Blümchen kaufen sollen. - Ja.
Es war einfach so, dass wir
Christine zurücklassen mussten.
Sie war krank. Wir konnten sie
nicht mit auf die Flucht nehmen.
Wir haben sie dann einfach
im Spital lassen müssen.
Weil ...
Sie ist dann sowieso gestorben.
Aber auf der Flucht ...
... wäre sie ... da hatte man
die Hoffnung,
dass sie vielleicht gerettet wird.
* Schniefen *
Schon gut.
* Schluchzen *
Ich bewundere dich.
* Sanfte, ergreifende Musik *
Jetzt musst du auch noch weinen.
Ja, klar.
Ach, du Arme.
Für Barbara und ihren Mann
geht die Reise morgen weiter -
noch tiefer in die Vergangenheit,
die sie geprägt hat.
* Beschwingte, exotische Musik *
Vom Kinderheim, das keines mehr ist,
will Sairah heute noch
an einen anderen Ort.
Sie hat die Adresse
der Agentur gefunden,
die damals
ihre Adoption geregelt hat.
Es war gleichzeitig
auch ein Kinderheim.
Gehen wir in diese Richtung.
P53.
- Ja.
In Indien sind die Nummern
immer ziemlich ...
P53?
* Sie sprechen Hindi. *
63.
(Mann)
I think you have been here before.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you. Bye.
Diese Spur führt ins Leere.
Irgendwo in dieser riesigen Stadt
versteckt sich Sairahs Vergangenheit.
Vielleicht
ist nur ein kleiner Hinweis da,
vielleicht aber auch ein Verwandter,
Geschwister oder ihre Mutter.
Sairah will morgen weitersuchen -
nach etwas Vertrautem
in dieser fremden Heimat.
* Ruhige, nachdenkliche Musik *
Barbara und Markus
reisen heute weiter Richtung Polen.
Sie wollen nach Kolberg,
in Barbaras Geburtsstadt.
Damals war das noch Deutschland.
Ich habe den Ort, an dem ich eine
glückliche Jugend verbracht habe,
und dann auf brutale Art und Weise
verlassen musste,
75 Jahre nicht gesehen.
Wahrscheinlich
ist alles anders geworden.
Auf der Gefühlsebene
ist es für mich viel einfacher.
Es ist ein fremder Ort,
der neu für mich ist.
Ich besuche den Ort und weiss,
dass dort meine Herzallerliebste
geboren wurde
und ihre Kindheit
teils dort verbracht hat.
Äh ...
Es ist aber beklemmend für mich,
wenn ich an deine Reaktion denke.
Und dann möchte ich dich
einfach in die Arme nehmen.
Nächste Woche
bei "Meine fremde Heimat":
Barbara ist in Kolberg,
wo sie zur Welt gekommen ist.
Von diesem Ort musste sie mit
ihrer Familie vor dem Krieg flüchten.
Man hat irgendwie immer
einen Rest Sehnsucht in sich
nach dem Ort,
an dem man geboren wurde
und die Kindheit verbracht hat -
und jetzt ist es fremd.
Und Sairah
erlebt ihr Heimatland Indien.
Trotz Rückschlägen hat sie die Suche
nach ihrer leiblichen Familie
noch nicht aufgegeben.
Wo ich im Moment
mit meiner Suche stehe?
Also ... eigentlich ...
... bei Null.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
L. Zbinden, D. Zacheo - 2020